que bom pessoal a nossa primeira vítima
da faca quente foi o nosso iphone 6 mais
um só como ficou e como vocês pediram
muito hoje vamos tentar então faca
quente contra enoque 3310 descansar o
vídeo aqui é só agradecer o caso porque
ele conseguiu arranjar este nokia antigo
pra [ __ ] que há nenhuma loja vendeu e
pré arranjar o jogador foi muito difícil
estava sem bateria fez o que é que o
início tivemos que fazer para conseguir
carregar o o nokia ligação direta
ligação direta
eu vou ficar eu vou estar buscando
pessoal basicamente este acabou aqui era
destes quero isso é pra carregar dentro
do carro e eu tive que cortar este carro
e unir e 51 carro do pici e acabou spa
um cabo usb e depois que ganhamos os 33
no pcb mesmo só isso que eu vou um dia
inteiro a procurar o carregador a fazer
a união é ver na internet como
poderíamos fazer isso meu um dia inteiro
fazer só para carregar esta [ __ ] e vai
só está a funcionar a nokia funciona
vejam só pessoal não está o dia antes de
cortá la musique o nokia com o fato
envolve só a estrada que algumas coisas
que eu adorava na altura o quanto este
telemóvel só jogava snake' eu acho que é
da oceanic dois tinham um joguinho quero
aqui principais invadidas quer com as
naves que disparavam tiros de ativos com
a produção administrativa vamos lá então
a lista dos jogos que deve ser augusta
kyoto ensinei dois players impacto banco
me que já nem me lembro é que tem o pé
aos dois buscar que o senai para
escolinhas no paulo estausia pra [ __ ]
aí no jogo olha aí eu jogava muito
isto já comeu uma maçã olha a cobra não
vai atrasar por seu lugar transporte
também lagartada um bônus e val mais do
que uma maçã aranha jato muito grande
para a minha cobra bem grande e foi o
que ela disse e supostamente o jogo
acaba quando nós conseguimos comer as
moças todas ou quando batemos na própria
e cobras podem só morrerá em outro jogo
extraordinário x e eu era muito difícil
ter um vício muito grande e muito isso
aqui é muito né
falei isso aqui manda mísseis haja morri
[ __ ] faltar lutar lutar só é isso
mas cansa muito de domingo cansa muito
dele
só vou fazer aqui uma chamada e vestindo
azul teve a qualidade do som que possuem
boas e antiga porque já não lembro mesmo
um tanto que não é quito o chamado agora
321 vai contar que produzam contag
cancelou o alerta que o número mostra
não mostrou o sol o papa isso não é bom
entender totô isso não teria outra rocha
não só os sons ou olá pessoal consegue
um novo teste de som um só como vocês
puderam ver funciona mil a consolidar
sua ainda é muito boa que nós temos em
2017 sem praiano em 2017 anos ainda tem
uma qualidade do [ __ ] o que tem mais
duas vezes deve ter mensagem aqui
encontradas apagaram tudo safado tem
sons falta no robinho surge aqui no meio
do golfo
a dona do imóvel onde eu sei como é que
[Música]
as duas crises ambiental
eu queria que além do nokia samsung não
é isto este também não é só sabem que de
um momento para o outro eles não falam
que toca à lei mas não só vamos ao que
interessa vamos lá tentar a faca quente
no nosso nokia 33 nessa inversão existe
o primeiro passo é conhecer a faca não
podia passar segurança segurança sempre
na cabeça do bicho e qualquer coisa
dentro do deus uma aranha tem qualquer
coisa e juruá [ __ ] só o texto
o sul é de que será fácil quero avançar
com uma meta eu tenho quase quase
certeza que este nokia 5310 vai assistir
a faca quente eu tenho quase a certeza
se nós conseguirmos chegar aos 100 mil
likes mais uma vez que eu vou tentar
destruir o meu nokia 3310 na imprensa
dos titulados meu nada consegue resistir
aqui o quanto vamos tentar lá também e
agora vamos aquecer faca
vejam só pessoal já está a ficar bem
vermelho cara está muito que desta vez
junto sentir o calor bpm playmil krall
só mil causa olha aí também vermelho já
são 32
uai meu deus num jardim go i go
já o ovo a manteiga e creme dental eu
senti um tal já falei e brutal violência
só vou tentar aquecer mais que dar um
corte ainda mais profundo
o cara está ali tá fogo que por lei o
fumo só vai profissão que uma reprodução
fiel vai-vai 321 vai cortar ainda mais
profundo na faca sem lavar vai 321 vai
lei manteiga oie sua bateria estava
encharcado e eu fiquei com a faca que
também é que o consumo popular eu acho
que toquei na bateria na produção da
yoki com muito cuidado não faço isso em
casa pessoal sério não façam isso em
casa olha aí produção
esta parte que o chupa-cabra de juro eu
vou tentar abrir nokia é uma instituição
foi só tinha razão aparente só que eu
consegui tocar cortar pela bateria ela
quase que exibem toda bateria e número
ea vejam só o buraco qualquer solo agora
vou tentar dar o outro corpo ainda mais
profundo mas sem bateria lá é porque
esporte clube
eu não sei se eu gostei mesmo
acho que ainda funciona todo
[Música]
ok só vamos esperar que fique
completamente quente e eu vou tentar
fazer o máximo de força que o conseguir
vou tentar basicamente disparar o nokia
maio encosta-se mesmo perguntar preto já
é faca negra de amor
ok pessoal mais um minuto e eu acho que
já estavam pai e produção conta com 321
vai sou mãe mas sem força olha aí possuo
do sul porém viu deus por tudo só esta
parte não corta por supostamente que
leva o total é bem mais difícil mas
quase conseguia
eu pensei que isto noc existir a faca
quente mas pelo que eu vou pôr a pagar
né mas ainda tenho que esta parte do
total portanto se conseguiram chegar aos
100 milex essa foi a meta eu vou tentar
acabar com o que resta de londrina pensa
dos toneladas mas o que é isto ver o
elenco mil euros para o nokia é em
inglês 34 do caso
ainda tenho uma teoria a desvantagem
deste noc 33 vezes é que é tudo feito de
plástico e eo nosso iphone é feito de
alumínio no total e é porque é um tipo 2
é muito mais rápido né
acho que dá pra chamar eu vou prometer e
alencar por aí eu já não dá porque teria
sangrado frias era eu sei que eu vou
fazer o que eu sou eu sou químico
experiente já a folha.com light pessoal
e vamos testar o nosso 9 33 10 na
presença do outro lado
o túnel já sente o cheiro na china há
muito tempo mas que já viu jamais formas
mais importante que só quer que a
produção usados é que do vosso lado
vocês têm dois filhos provavelmente
ainda não viram e em cima nesta bola
vocês podem se inscrever é grátis
pessoal do avião fica espero ficar à
espera de um minuto espera rápida
produção está cansada pessoal é só se
inscrever de graça e levou à rápida
produção está cansada
funcionei já sabem quanto posso atribuir
não com freqüência não existem as provas
não é só aqui só 100 mil likes e nós
vamos mandar nosso 33 mesmo quinto vamos
mandar o nosso 33 na província
postulados e visto que este é o primeiro
vídeo de 2010 e tem que entrar com o pé
direito é portanto vamos entrar com o pé
direito já entrou com o pé direito
pessoal e é ele quem vai até a próxima